let's turn now to person where U.S
President Joe Biden has said that his
relationship with the United Kingdom is
Rock Solid Biden of course met with the
UK prime minister Rishi sunak at 10
Downing Street a few hours ago he's also
met with King Charles at Windsor Castle
the U.S president is on a three-nation
trip to Europe that will culminate in a
NATO Summit which gets underway in
Lithuania on Tuesday let's speak to
Nadine barber who is a Downing Street
for us Nadeem let's start with that
meeting between Rishi sunak and
President Biden it took place a few
hours ago it was very brief we know that
they weren't on the same page when it
came to Cluster Munitions which the U.S
has promised to Ukraine do we know if
that topic came up in the conversation
what else was said
well yes as you said it was very brief
barely 40 minutes before President Biden
made his way to Windsor yes we know from
Downing street that the um issue of the
U.S supplying those cluster bombs to
Ukraine an announcement that was made
last Friday did come up the prime
minister's spokesman uh in the last hour
or so saying that um basically the
decision seems to have been forced upon
the Americans
um due to what the spokesman said was
Russia's war of aggression in Ukraine
for the last few days the British have
been stressing that their signatories to
this convention which bans the
production and use of those cluster
Munitions
um but certainly it's not going to cause
any kind of major Rift between the US
and the UK bigger issues over Ukraine
include president zielinski's bid for
membership he's been pushing for a long
time now and at every occasion he
stresses the importance to his country
of joining NATO the Americans are fairly
to to act quickly President Biden before
he arrived in Britain reminding people
that with the conflict ongoing it simply
wouldn't be possible to think about
Ukraine being a member but talked that's
what the ukrainians want there could be
movement on that uh at the Lithuania
Summit and then there's the idea of
Sweden's membership they were supposed
to join earlier this year they have been
held up notably by turkey possibly Rishi
sunak being involved in trying to smooth
things over there so bigger issues at
stake at that Lithuania Summit I think
and the other thing is that 10 Downing
Street is stressing that um they do but
the British do actually uh see eye to
eye with the Americans on Ukraine
joining NATO saying that we do want to
support Ukraine on the pathway to
joining the alliance so the pathway
possibly strengthening the relationship
in the next few months offering them uh
closer ties not saying we're going to
Green Light your accession
and a much longer meeting between
President Biden and King Charles they're
currently having tea together at Windsor
Castle and if body language is anything
to go by it's been very warmly received
how significant is that meeting
I think it is fairly significant and you
mentioned the body language I think
there's a better report between King
Charles and President Biden perhaps
notably because they share this interest
which is the climate crisis Prince
Charles uh sorry King Charles has been
uh raising the issue of biodiversity and
uh the climate uh crisis for decades and
um even after he was crowned he he made
it clear that although he's not supposed
to be involved in politics he'd like to
do what he can to get things moving and
notably he and the president are meeting
delegates to a forum which are trying to
raise money to help developing nations
fight uh climate change right now of
course um Buckingham Palace is stressing
that he is not intervening politically
but it's an issue close to his heart so
yeah they've met before they met at the
cop 26 climate Summit in Scotland two
years ago where President Biden told the
then Prince Charles we need you badly so
I think all of these talks behind the
scenes and do help and let's not forget
that President Biden of course has his
own very extensive plans for the green
economy something which many countries
here in Europe perhaps are trying to
emulate and some of prime minister sunax
critics are saying should actually take
a leaf out to President Biden's book
whatever the case yes friendly friendly
relations there but not very long
because of course President Biden's big
business is getting to Lithuania at the
end of Monday for that Summit okay thank
you for that update Nadine barber there
for us at Downing Street